hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
today we're interviewing Emily skarbek
of the independent Institute based in
the Bay Area in California she's the
director of entrepreneurial innovation
at the independent Institute Emily
thanks for joining us thanks for having
me Nick okay your PhD economist from
George Mason a good libertarian
education educational outfit or at least
certainly in terms of its economics
department you've got a website that's
been up for a bit at the independent
Institute tell us what it is and what
you're hoping to do with so we have two
independent Institute put together this
website it's called my gov cos org and
it has a government cost calculator
available for people to just come and
use freely and take a look at what it is
that these government spending programs
these federal spending programs are
costing them personally okay and you're
you're able to go through that and you
you enter your age you enter your
educational level and you enter your
current income and then it will create a
series of charts and graphs that show
how much the government is spending from
your tax tape right absolutely Mick but
the most unique aspect of the calculator
which is really cool is that it shows
what the value of those dollars would
otherwise be worth if you didn't have
them taken from you and you could invest
them privately in the market you're
figuring on an investment return of
about six percent right yeah very
conservative just baseline estimate but
the reason why this is important is
because in all of these debates about
federal spending and we agree it's
wildly out of control and the debate has
zoned in on what areas really need to be
cut but the true cost of government
spending are still being underestimated
because the in officious inefficiencies
in state production of goods and
services are not reflected in just your
tax bill but really reflected in what
you could otherwise be purchasing with
those dollars if you didn't have to give
them to the government so it's I mean
it's looking at kind of opportunity
costs right absolutely what are some of
the big surprises I work through some
numbers I of course added a bit
part of my salary that i actually have
but when I looked at social security
because you break it down into what
about two dozen categories all of the
major spending categories that people
are interested in defense spending
Social Security Medicare Medicaid these
types of things as well as environmental
regulations things like that I agree
with you it's a really cool site it
generates information immediately and
that opportunity cost of what your share
say of funding Medicare or social
security could be going to if you were
able to invest it and get at six percent
return with Social Security I mean what
what do we find I mean are we going to
get as much out of Social Security as we
would if we were able to take our the
Social Security contribution from our
FICA taxes and put it on the market yeah
I think that that's one of the most
surprising things that people will see
when they come and use the calculator is
that for just you know a basic you know
college graduate who's you know coming
out entering the job market they could
expect to turn their contributions from
Social Security into a you know over a
million and a half dollars that they
could use over the course of their
lifetime to spend in any way they please
and instead what they're going to be
looking at is you know maybe a two
percent return tops and probably
negative returns for people that are
under the age of 55 or so so that's
pretty fascinating what about defense I
mean because the big-spending ticket
items in the federal budget are social
security their defense Medicare and
Medicaid what can we see when we look at
how much defense spending is being paid
for by an individual's tax take this is
why the the calculator can be used for
you know people on both sides of the
fence but the idea is that the defense
spending is absolutely out of control
and when you look at where your dollars
are going and if you are like I am and
are morally outraged by our escapades in
in foreign policy then you can use this
as a tool to share share your outrage
with others and spread the word on to
what these what these spending programs
are costing how will you how do you
measure success with
this intervention into the public debate
what itwhat itwhat to what's a hope for
outcome for the independent Institute
and you regarding this calculator well
we really want to provide a level of
transparency and start this discussion
in on how it is that we move towards
real rule-based changes in public policy
so that's we on the website we provide a
lot of news and resources links two
general ways in which people can take
this information and and really use it
in in developing their own ideas but I I
just like the fact that in emphasizing
the opportunity cost of government
spending we really open up this debate
of I can't we be more creative of how we
go about servicing the goods and
services that we've now turned over to
the state to produce most of the things
that the government spending our money
on are things that the market provides
really really well and so by emphasizing
this we hope to kind of allow people to
venue to start talking about that share
the results on Twitter on Facebook and
just move the discussion in a new and
progressive direction are you when you
look over the next two four six years do
you think that Americans are starting to
get it that they are starting to realize
that we have a government that is
unsustainable are you optimistic that
we're going to reel it back in I guess
I'm somewhat optimistic i mean you know
there has been a palpable shift in the
way in which people are talking about
federal spending and the role of the
federal government in our private and
public public lives and that to me i
think is an important and recognizable
change in the trend of ideas all right
well emily skarbek director of
entrepreneurial innovation at the
independent institute and the director
of the my gov cost website it's
something that everybody should check at
it I mean it you'll learn a lot I know
this is one of those things that put me
after looking at it it put me in a short
term depression but a longer term sense
of optimism because like you were saying
its transparency gives you a really
strong sense
what your government tax dollars are
going to across all sorts of spending
items and more important what they could
be doing elsewise Emily I want to thank
you and the independent Institute for
getting it out there thanks so much
you